Joe: A Brit and an American swap countries
to try each other's McDonald's.
This is "Food Wars."
We'll start with some things
you can find in the UK
but I think might be
slightly different over here.
Let's start with the
iconic McDonald's Big Mac.
So, I mean, visually,
looks pretty much the same.
You've got the quite
sad, flimsy beef patties.
Let's give it a try.
So, I think there are some
subtle differences there,
actually. Like, broadly speaking,
if you gave it to me and were
like, "This is a UK Big Mac,"
I don't think I would doubt you.
I think it's the sauce,
because the UK Big Mac sauce
has got quite a tang to it,
almost, and this is very gentle.
I barely get anything from it.
The Big Mac. Now, this
looks exactly like a Big Mac
anywhere in the world.
You know what I gotta do. Oop and oop.
Now let's give this a shot.
If that isn't exactly
the same, it's close.
I mean, if I could do one side
by side I'd probably notice,
but I do not taste any difference.
I remember when we did
"Fast-Food Chemistry,"
you guys had more
chemicals and stuff to use,
but I'm here to say
the chemicals have not
made a striking difference.
It tastes almost exactly the same.
Then we're on to the fries and
the Coke aspect of the meal.
Firstly, I have to point
out how enormous these are.
The size of this drink is ridiculous.
This is way bigger
than almost any fast-food
drink I've seen in the UK ever.
Even the fries as well.
This box of fries is huge.
They've kind of sunk down a little bit,
so it doesn't really show how full it was.
But this carton is massive.
You can fit so many fries in here.
It feels like almost double the size
of a carton of UK fries.
I mean, these are pretty good.
I will say, I think they've
held up a lot better
after a bit of time out of the fryer
than UK fries have.
UK McDonald's fries, I think maybe
because they don't have
as many ingredients,
there aren't the preservative
chemicals in there,
they don't really hold
up very well at all.
As soon as they come out the fryer,
they kind of just get
worse and worse and worse.
So you have to eat them
really while they're hot.
I think taste-wise,
there are some slight differences as well.
There is something more than
just salt going on here.
So, I only know this because we made
that "Fast-Food Chemistry"
episode of McDonald's fries,
but there is a sort of
artificial-beef flavor
that's added to these, and
you do kind of taste it.
It's very subtle, but there's a kind of
savory depth of flavor to these
that you just don't get in the UK.
I kind of like it. I can't lie.
My first thing about these fries,
these guys are pale looking.
Not the bright yellow I'm
used to in the States.
The whole thing is just potato,
salt, and oil, that's it?
Yeah, and I believe it,
because these are bland.
Man!
What?
Mm-mm, no on the fries.
USA ones are way better.
And then finally, this
enormous McDonald's Coke.
I don't know what it is
about McDonald's Coke,
but it just always hits different.
That happens in the UK
and, yeah, kind of still happens here.
Another iconic menu item
that I thought was worth
trying was McNuggets.
So, just visually speaking,
before I even try it,
these look quite different
to British McNuggets.
I'm fairly sure the ones
in the UK are deep-fried.
Correct me if I'm wrong, editor.
But these ones look almost
more deep-fried somehow,
just in terms of the way that the breading
has kind of puffed up and
blistered a little bit.
I will say, I think the breading
maybe has slightly more seasoning,
a bit more flavor going
on here than I'm used to.
The chicken itself I think
is pretty much the same.
I think I might prefer
British nuggets. Sorry, guys.
Nuggets look like almost
exactly the same size,
smell the same, same amount
of crispness on the skin.
No, much blander. Much blander.
You guys are getting a terrible deal
with these nuggets, because this is dry.
I did notice it says
"100% chicken breast meat"
on this one.
I do not know if that's
the case in America.
Can we get that on-screen?
But I've just been informed, no,
of the chicken that they use,
100% of it is chicken breast meat,
but it's only 45% chicken, right?
It says "100% chicken breast" on it.
The implication there is that
the chicken is 100% chicken,
or it's 100% chicken meat.
It is not. Deceptive!
The last thing we wanted to compare
in both countries was the McCrispy.
Here is an American McCrispy.
It looks fairly similar
to ours on the surface.
This one I think is a
potato roll rather than
the more pretzel-y brioche version
that you find in the UK.
There's no sauce.
It's just pickles and
a fried chicken patty.
I really like the pickles.
I think pickles and fried
chicken is a great combination,
and it's not super common in the UK.
I will say, I think it needs a sauce.
I think technically they claim
that they butter the rolls
and that butter is I
guess therefore the sauce,
but it's kind of dry.
The chicken's just a
little bit thin as well.
I feel like the McCrispy
in the UK tends to be
a thicker and slightly
juicier piece of chicken.
This is a fairly thin and
quite dry chicken breast.
The McCrispy.
Harry: Yellow box.
Oh, nice! All right.
I'm pleasantly surprised by the bun.
It reminds me of King's Hawaiian rolls.
Yeah, this looks like our McChicken.
It is so close to the McChicken.
Better bun than the McChicken,
but the crispiness of the chicken patty.
It tastes slightly different.
I would say the McChicken sauce is,
I hate to say it, is a bit sweeter.
Because I love the McChicken.
Like, the taste of that is in my DNA.
Here are all the US menu items
you won't find at a UK McDonald's.
Here's all the UK McDonald's menu items
I can't get in the US.
We'll start with some chicken options,
namely the deluxe McCrispy
and the spicy deluxe McCrispy.
Let's take a look at the deluxe McCrispy
and see what exactly they're
adding to make it deluxe.
The roll looks pretty much the
same as the standard version.
The chicken looks the same.
But I think when they say deluxe,
that just means they've added
mayo, lettuce, and tomato.
I don't know if that is enough
to qualify something as deluxe.
Doesn't seem super deluxe to me.
I also think that tomato is
just a bad topping for a burger.
They've kind of made this
worse, in my opinion.
I'm going to take a bite
of the spicy one and see
if it's good and if it's spicy.
It does have some heat to
it. They weren't kidding.
For my measly British-person palate.
I think I would probably
just buy the regular version
of the McCrispy and then
add some sauce to it.
So, you got a bacon mayo
chicken and a mayo chicken.
No, this might be exactly
what the McChicken's like.
Nah, it's a little wimpier.
Yeah. Is this what you're talking about?
Like, it's a big McNugget? Yeah.
The mayo's weird. Has a
really stale aftertaste.
I'm telling you, your guys'
breaded chicken at McDonald's
has no flavor compared
to the one in the US.
The McCrispy was crispier,
had more flavor in the sauce,
and the bun was nicer.
Yeah, this is a bummer.
Ugh, we got the same with
bacon. Do I really have to ...
No.
Look at how flimsy your bacon is.
Now we're on to some beef options,
starting with the McDouble.
I have just some kind
of existential questions
about the McDouble.
Namely, why does it exist?
Because we have the double cheeseburger.
Let's give it try.
I'm genuinely curious,
like, how is this different
to just a double cheeseburger, Joe?
One slice of cheese. Joe
says one slice of cheese.
Talk me through it.
OK, so what's going on
here is that the McDouble
has one slice of cheese in between,
where with double cheese, we
have two slices of cheese.
I think that's the only difference.
I honestly think it's, right,
because this is just, like,
the standard McDonald's.
Yeah, this looks very normal.
Right? It's just one less slice of cheese
from what we can tell. And
the price difference is,
let's get that on-screen.
So if you want to save
that amount of money,
get yourself a McDouble
and pass the savings on to you.
There you go. Cheers, Joe.
You heard it here first.
Next up we have the Quarter
Pounder with cheese deluxe.
So, similarly to the McCrispy,
they've turned this thing
into a deluxe burger
by just adding some lettuce,
some mayo, and some tomato.
You know what they've tried to do here?
They've tried to just make a Whopper.
This is the double Quarter
Pounder with bacon.
Now this is a burger.
This one does what you would
expect a Quarter Pounder to do.
It's just loads of meat and cheese.
I want to talk more
about this bacon as well,
because this bacon's good.
One thing that I think we
do quite badly in the UK
at fast food is bacon.
A lot of the bacon you'll
find on UK restaurants
is this very pallid pink color,
whereas this one, stronger flavor,
you get some smokiness from it.
The bacon on this is way better,
and therefore that makes
it a very enjoyable burger.
Yes, I think the deluxe
should just be more beef
and some bacon rather than vegetables
that no one wants to eat. Come on.
Oh, yeah, now we're talking. Two patties.
Although, I'm telling you
guys, the patty on patty
with nothing in the middle is just weird.
A poppy-sesame-seed-bun hybrid?
Whoa!
Yeah, it doesn't look like barbecue sauce.
Barbecue sauce is, like, an amber brown.
Eh.
I think the bacon kind of screws it up
because your bacon is so flimsy.
I think this would work
with American bacon,
because American bacon would
just be, like, crisp —
I mean, it's not like
it has to be crispier.
It's just, this is really rubbery.
What do you guys think barbecue sauce is?
Bacon double cheeseburger.
I'm not impressed with
your bacon here, guys.
I'm not impressed.
Look. Look at ...
everyone in America,
look how weird this is.
Yeah, like ...
I'm pretty sure we had a
bacon double cheeseburger
at some point at McDonald's,
and it wasn't like this.
Our bacon is crispier, more
dispersed evenly, I guess.
Just have two strips going
right through the middle here.
That's a disaster. It's a total disaster!
All right, McPlant. Harry, get in here
and explain to me what
I'm doing, what this is.
This is the McPlant. It's
McDonald's fake-meat burger.
It took them ages to develop this.
They tested it in Scandinavia first.
It was available in Sweden for a while.
They also developed their own vegan cheese
because McDonald's couldn't
find a commercial vegan cheese
that they thought was good enough.
Yeah, I believe it. Look at
this. This looks terrifying.
I'll leave you to it, buddy.
Thanks, bud. What he said.
I think it was only available
in a few places in the US.
Came and went.
So, at least the US audience,
not impressed with the McPlant.
Yeah, that's not good.
There is definitely some
plant-based meat that tastes good,
that tastes like meat.
This ain't it.
I want to take this moment
to try your UK Coca-Cola.
Man, the Coke here is way better.
You guys make it with real sugar.
F--- off with this!
Does this ... ?
And these are the dippers, right?
Who do you think you are, McDonald's?
Who do you think you are, doing this?
You just took the dippers and put them ...
Oh, God, gross!
What is this, like ... what is this?
Vegetables.
Yo, this sucks ass, dude.
Yeah, the vegetarian says he loves them.
Put a asterisk next to that.
Of all the things he
can eat at McDonald's,
there's two, right?
And this is one of them. So OK, great.
I never want this.
Moving on.
Ah, Chicken Selects.
This is closer to what our McChicken
and our nuggets taste like.
Oh, yeah.
Damn, wish we had this in America.
The sour cream and chive
dip is really good.
Here are all the
exclusive wraps and salads
that you can find in the US
that you won't find in the UK.
That's not a mistake. There
are just none of them.
It's not even that there's no exclusives.
There's just no wraps
or salads, full stop,
on a US McDonald's menu.
Joe: USA!
I can't exactly say that
the UK salads are good
at McDonald's, but at least
we have them, you know?
You have an option if you
somehow are trying to eat healthy
but have ended up in a McDonald's anyway.
Whereas in America the closest
thing you have to a salad
is this bag of apple slices.
Oh, my God. I hate wraps.
This is a really smart way
of presenting this. A pita.
Isn't that a pita?
Harry: Tortilla, isn't it?
Oh, yeah. I guess it's
closer to a tortilla.
Leon: Also, the way you say it.
Joe: "Peed-a."
Leon: Yeah.
How do you say it?
Leon: "Pit-ta."
No, that's wrong. It's
with an I. "Peed-a."
Charlie: I would say "pit-ta."
Well, you'd be wrong.
Ugh, what kind of dressing is this?
Well, it says garlic, but
it's not very garlicky.
OK, so then we have the
grilled version of this. Yeah.
No, no, no, no, no.
What flavor could this possibly have?
Oh, come on.
Charlie: I thought that
was a bit of bread!
No.
Oh, man. That has no flavor.
Yeah, you can get a grilled-
or crispy-chicken salad,
but we didn't get them
because I didn't fly across
the planet to eat a salad.
Hey, this is fun. Nacho cheese wedges.
Well, we're much further from Mexico,
so how good could the
nacho cheese actually be?
Not bad.
It's certainly the most
flavorful thing I've eaten today.
Now it's time for the
exclusive condiments,
and you know what that means.
S-s-s-s-s-s-sauce talk.
The very first sauce
talk, "Foreign Exchange."
Sauce talk.
We're going to start with
this one, spicy Buffalo.
Yeah, so I think that's
the same one that they put
on the spicy McCrispy.
It's pretty good. It's basically
like if you take a mayo
and just pour some Frank's RedHot in it.
Let's try the honey mustard out.
I personally love a honey mustard.
You certainly get the
honey. It's pretty good.
I think the balance of that
is more on the honey side,
and it needs to swing slightly
more to the mustard side.
Now, this one I'm excited for.
It's ranch. We call it
"rahnch," not ranch.
Yeah, that's pretty good.
Yeah, it's got a sort of herby tang to it.
Then we've got a couple of condiments
which are technically breakfast items
but we're going to count
under sauce talk anyway.
We'll start with the mild picante salsa.
I think this is supposed to be paired
with the breakfast burrito,
which we will get onto later.
But I'm going to try it with a nugget.
Joe: Oh, Jesus.
OK, that's enough.
Just do it.
Does what it says on the tin.
That's just a mild salsa, really.
Also on the breakfast-condiments list,
we have hotcake syrup.
I guess, like, maybe
legally they're not allowed
to call it maple syrup, so hotcake syrup.
I mean, people eat pancakes
with bacon and maple syrup,
so why can't chicken nuggets
and maple syrup go together?
OK, I thought I'd invented
something special there,
but nope, turns out I cannot claim
that combination as my own.
It's butter.
They have butter on the menu.
I think, again, designed to
be used with the hotcakes.
The final condiment
option is some grape jam.
I will say, we don't tend to have many
grape-flavored products in
the UK for whatever reason.
Mm.
Joe: Yeah?
It's pretty tasty.
Maybe not in combination with the chicken,
but the grape jam is quite nice.
Already, your ketchup, it's bizarre.
It makes sense why this would be ketchup,
considering what ketchup is.
But American ketchup is way sweeter.
I don't know if that's a
good thing or a bad thing,
but I'm eating that, and I'm like,
if that was on a plate,
I was eating somewhere
that that was on a plate
and I was dipping into it,
I'd be like, "Oh, what sauce is this?"
Because I wouldn't think that's ketchup.
Like, "Oh, it's this fun
tomato sauce you got."
I wouldn't go, "Oh, ketchup."
Yeah, it's that different.
OK, the barbecue sauce, from
the country with no barbecue.
Let's see what you guys
think barbecue is. Nope.
I don't know what this is supposed to be.
Sweet chili dip. Here we go.
Better. Just OK.
McDonald's barbecue sauce is its own
special brand of barbecue sauce.
Yeah, this is pretty close to it, but
this one's a little more mustardy.
So, OK. Yeah, it's not bad.
All right, sweet and sour.
Ooh, that's really good.
Oh, hell yeah, dude. Sweet
curry. Been waiting for this.
That's really good!
We don't have any exclusive options
when it comes to the
food inside a Happy Meal,
but I did want to get one and just kind of
see what the vibe was, see
what the toy is, crucially.
So, at the time of recording this,
"The Little Mermaid"
hit theaters recently,
so they seem to be doing a
collab with "The Little Mermaid."
Does that mean I'm going to
get a "Little Mermaid" toy?
Let's find out.
So, we get — oh, these fries are so cute.
So, this is a UK large. [Joe laughing]
This is what I'm used to.
I will say, in the UK, the
fries come in a paper bag
rather than one of these
simply adorable little cartons,
which, honestly, huge fan of.
I went for the McNuggets,
which tend to come in a box of four.
Ah, there you go. You get
the apple slices within that.
This is the American salad.
And, of course, we get a toy.
Oh, it's King Triton! Let's go!
"Place your toy on a phone
or tablet for more fun,"
which I do think we have
to try and do real quick.
OK, try again. OK, put it down.
Put my phone on the desk.
You guys are getting this, right?
Getting all of this? This is crucial.
Place your toy on there. Pick a thing.
I'll just go there.
OK. Play the game.
"Turn your sound on."
[water swooshing]
I'm going to be honest. This is a miss.
Some kind of pattern? "Learn pattern."
That one, that one.
[water swooshing]
Did it. I win.
DC Happy Meal.
I've been told that it's —
one second. We got the toy.
Oh, Poison Ivy. Fast-food
fish is way more popular here.
You guys love your fast fish. I do not.
It smells fishy.
For the first time,
your food being flavorless
is a good thing.
Fries. Yeah, actually,
I would say this is also our kids size.
Let's take a look at the Poison Ivy toy.
What the hell? What is — OK.
Oh, there's something inside.
Ah, stickers, a game.
All right. Fun for kids.
Now we're on to some
McCafé and dessert options.
Unfortunately, I couldn't
get a few of these,
but here are the ones that
I was able to find today.
We'll start with a good
old-fashioned American
chocolate chip cookie.
This looks pretty good.
We're kind of bad at cookies in the UK.
I don't know what it
is, but they tend to be
very dry and crumbly
rather than soft and chewy.
That's not bad.
What's more American than apple pie?
I'll tell you what, an
apple pie from McDonald's.
This is the American McDonald's apple pie.
In the UK, a McDonald's apple
pie is actually deep-fried.
It just looks very different.
This is a baked apple pie,
so you get more of a lattice going on.
You see the filling there, but it's baked,
so I guess they don't need
to seal it on every side
because it's not going in a fryer.
It's not all going to
spill out into the oil.
I don't know if it's
going to hold up or not.
I think the UK might be
doing better apple pies
than the US is, at least
when it comes to McDonald's.
The pastry's fine.
The filling tastes pretty much identical
to the filling of a UK apple pie.
But yeah, like, the baked pastry
is just not the same as fried pastry.
And then there's actually
another pie option
on the menu right now at a US McDonald's.
This one is a strawberry cream pie.
That's pretty good.
As I said, there were
some desserts and pastries
that we weren't able to
get today. Here they are.
In the UK, you can also
get exclusive McFlurries.
Could not get them because,
you're not going to believe it,
but the ice cream machines
are also broken in the UK.
You can get yourself a Maltesers McFlurry
and a Smarties McFlurry.
OK, we got the McCafé snacks.
First up, oh, a doughnut.
Hey, who doesn't like a doughnut?
Ooh, yo!
This one is covered in
sugar. Look at that.
Muffin. Berry. Berry muffin.
A millionaire's doughnut, huh?
Ooh, with the cream inside?
It is pretty decadent.
I don't know if I feel like a millionaire.
I don't think millionaires
are eating those,
I'm going to be honest with you.
Oh, hell yeah. Oh, yeah.
Yep. That's a good cookie.
Let's talk about the drinks.
First of all, there are
some hot and cold coffees
which are available in both countries.
It does seem like the US
actually has a bigger range
of coffees, particularly when
it comes to the iced versions,
while in the UK we're limited
to a couple of basic ones
like an iced latte. Over
here you can get all sorts.
You can get things like
your iced caramel mocha,
your frappa mochaccino,
Dunkin' thingymajiggy.
You know the ones.
There are some interesting
non-coffee drinks though
that I do want to try and talk about now.
We're going to start with
this one down the end,
which I believe is Hawaiian Punch.
Not common in the UK at all.
Joe: [laughs] Yep.
OK.
If this is the first one,
I think I have a bit
of a storm coming here.
It's pretty good, but, wow, is that sweet.
This one is an American-style lemonade.
As I've said before in the show,
lemonade in the UK is like Sprite.
It's, like, a clear,
carbonated lemony beverage,
whereas this looks like
a good old-fashioned
American lemonade.
It's not bad. It's weird to me
that lemonade isn't carbonated,
but that's pretty good. That's
actually fairly refreshing,
unlike maybe the Hawaiian Punch was.
Also, happy birthday, Grimace,
while we're on the subject.
They did have a special Grimace shake,
but the ice cream machine was broken
at the McDonald's that
we went to, of course,
so I haven't been able
to get the Grimace shake,
which I'm really sad about.
Here's what it's supposed to look like.
They do not have a good
old-fashioned cup of tea
on the menu at an American McDonald's.
What they do have is sweet tea.
I felt like I had to try it as a Brit.
You know, I have to give my
thoughts on everyone's teas.
Aah.
Joe: [laughs] No!
They weren't kidding when
they called it sweet tea.
So, this was supposed to be a
blue-raspberry frozen Fanta,
and this was supposed to be a frozen Coke.
However, now it is just a
melted blue-raspberry Fanta
and a melted Coke,
otherwise known as Coke.
Ooh. That's pretty good.
Yeah, just tastes like Coke.
It does somehow, like, still
has a bit of fizz to it,
and the same with the Fanta, actually.
I do think I would like
these if they were frozen.
I think on a really hot day, for example,
carrying a frozen Coke
around sounds delightful.
So, yeah, would quite like
those on the UK menu, maybe.
Then we have a, what I
believe to be, Hi-C drink,
Hi-C Orange Lavaburst.
Yeah, so this isn't carbonated,
and it's not fruit juice.
It's somewhere in the middle.
I'd put it reasonably close to an Oasis
that we can get in the UK,
which is also a sort of
non-carbonated fruity beverage.
I don't love it.
Last but by no means least,
we have milk on the menu.
I think this is kind of aimed at kids.
I never want to meet a
person who is a grown adult
and goes to McDonald's and
orders milk with their meal.
These are all the exclusive
drinks we got today.
There are some other
ones, and here they are.
All right, the McCafé exclusives.
They didn't label any of
them, so I'll just guess.
That's definitely hot
chocolate, but let's see,
how does it compare to the deluxe?
Mm-mm.
Oh, this is that butter
thing. That's terrible.
We'll get back to that. Let me
find the other hot chocolate.
That's a hot chocolate.
I can't tell the difference.
I don't know which one's
deluxe. Would deluxe be size?
Wait, this one has that
buttery oil floating in it.
And this, I know what this is.
Tea!
I don't get it. I don't
get why this is so popular.
The McCafé food's pretty good. I like it.
You got a good selection
here. The drinks, not so much.
I like banana, I like
banana-flavored stuff,
and we don't nearly have as
much in the United States.
This tastes exactly like a
banana Laffy Taffy. It's great.
What's Oasis?
Yeah, no, thanks.
I mean, it's sweet, but
it reminds me of Gatorade.
Orange juice. I know what
orange juice tastes like.
What is this? Robinsons Fruit Shoot.
Why is it a Fruit Shoot?
What's the shooting part?
Leon: It's for kids, really.
Oh, so it's just, like,
shoot it in my mouth,
like, "aah"? That what it's for?
Leon: I think it's called that
because kids are more likely
to be like, "Yeah, give me a Fruit Shoot."
Than what?
Leon: Than, like, "Give me a Coke."
I would like to know why
this is called Fruit Shoot.
OK, so I think it's called,
I haven't looked it up,
I think it's called Fruit
Shoot because it wants you
to squeeze, like, shoot it
in your mouth, like, "blah!"
And Leon thinks it's because
it sounds better than saying Coke.
Now we're going to talk
about the most important meal
of the day, breakfast.
We'll start with this one,
the steak and egg McMuffin.
That doesn't really look,
taste, or feel like a steak.
Now, next up, America has some
breakfast biscuit options.
So, from what I've seen,
a biscuit looks very much like a scone,
which is obviously a classic British dish.
Now, the fact that they would
be putting breakfast food,
like bacon, eggs, sausages,
into what is effectively
a scone is weird to me
and I think will be weird
to a lot of Brits as well.
So, this is just a
classic sausage biscuit.
It does look pretty like a scone.
It's maybe a bit more,
like, smooth on the outside
than I'm expecting from a scone.
So dry.
Joe: Told you.
Harry: Oh, my God.
Hey, Joe from "Food Wars" here.
I just wanted to say, that's not a scone.
It's a different biscuit.
I don't know what he's talking about.
He'll be chewing on that
for the next four minutes,
but it's different.
He's right. It's different.
It's not a scone. It's somehow worse.
Yeah, apparently I chose badly
with the sausage being my first one,
because that was dry as a desert.
So let's have a quick bite
of a bacon, egg, and cheese,
which is a classic American-slash-New
York breakfast combo.
It's still pretty dry, but the addition
of the other stuff definitely helps.
What are the takeaways there?
Scones and biscuits are
different, not the same.
A scone is a little bit more crumbly,
generally slightly sweeter.
These are not sweet.
Slightly more bready texture.
I'm still not convinced by
the notion of them as, like,
the foundation of a breakfast sandwich,
just mostly because of how dry they are.
But, hey, who am I to
judge American culture?
Now, these I'm excited for.
I've heard very good things
about these from Joe.
These are McDonald's McGriddles.
If I remember correctly
from watching Joe eat these,
they've got pancakes that
they sort of inject with syrup
and then use those as the
buns for a breakfast sandwich,
which sounds pretty excellent.
I'll try the bacon, egg, and
cheese. See how we get on.
Still slightly dry, but way less dry
than the biscuit, and very tasty.
I'm going to go even more syrup,
because what's better
than adding more syrup
to something which is
already full of syrup?
McGriddles, yes. Biscuits, not so sure.
So, this was the bacon,
egg, and cheese McGriddle.
You can also get McGriddles with sausage,
sausage and egg and cheese, or the steak,
which I will not be trying.
The next exclusive breakfast item
is the bacon, egg, and
cheese breakfast bagel.
We used to have bagels on the
menu at the UK McDonald's,
and they were wonderful.
Part of the breakfast menu,
toasted bagels with your choice
of toppings and fillings,
really good.
Pandemic hit, they cut them from the menu,
and they've not returned.
And personally, I'm furious about that.
Yeah. I've missed you so much, bagel.
Next up, we have a sausage burrito.
Breakfast burrito is really
not a thing in the UK.
We're just generally bad at Mexican food.
This is obviously designed to be enjoyed
with the mild salsa.
It's actually pretty good.
And then lastly on the
breakfast menu, we have these,
the Big Breakfasts.
The standard Big Breakfast
is a slab of scrambled egg,
a sausage patty, and a biscuit.
And this is the Big
Breakfast with hotcakes,
which is the egg, biscuit, and sausage
but then also comes with two pancakes.
Both of these come with dips,
including a little thing
of whipped butter and, of
course, the hotcake syrup.
So, I wasn't sure what the difference was
between pancakes and hotcakes.
Joe's just done a quick
Google, and apparently,
hotcakes tend to be a bit
thicker and denser than pancakes.
I mean, to me, that just
tastes like a pancake.
I'm thinking maybe they've
just called them hotcakes
to make them sound more
fancy or different,
but, yeah, not bad.
And, of course, McDonald's
UK, I gotta try the breakfast.
All right, first up,
the mini potato waffles,
hash browns that are shaped like a waffle.
I don't know why this specific shape.
Yeah, dude.
For some reason, it tastes
a lot better in waffle form.
I don't know why that is.
These are really good.
What do we got here? Breakfast sandwich.
This is the bacon roll with brown sauce.
It's like a hamburger bun! Look at this.
There's your brown sauce right there.
Hm. Eh.
It's just OK. Nothing special. It's bland.
I'm starting to think that you in the UK,
you guys don't like, your
stuff isn't as, like,
intense as ours in America is.
Like, this wouldn't fly
in the US because it's not
dripping with cheese and
doesn't have an egg in it
and the buns aren't, like, über-buttery.
It's just too plain. It's too boring.
This is the same thing with just ketchup.
Aw.
Now we're getting more in my speed.
This one has cheese and
bacon in it. Oh, yeah.
Is that sausage?
Yeah, this looks more like something
that you'd get in the US.
Yeah. Cheesy flatbread, oh, God.
Cheesy — oh, come on, guys.
Yeah, see, this is the bacon.
This is more like the bacon we're used to.
Charlie: So, that's streaky bacon.
Streaky bacon? So, this is bacon,
and the other thing was
Canadian bacon in the US.
I don't know why. Or ham,
I'm going to call it.
I mean, this just looks like,
I mean, this looks like whatever.
Yeah, this sucks. And that's why it sucks.
It's like, the flatbread is too strong.
I can barely taste the streaky bacon,
which is what I came here for, so.
Double sausage. OK, so with this,
you guys just went double meat on both.
Oh, man! Yo!
Look how much sausage is
in here. Look at that!
Hell yeah. Now we're talking, UK. See?
Although, nothing in between
the two sausage patties is, like,
it's gotta go cheese, meat, cheese, meat.
You can't just do meat. This doesn't work.
And possibly a sauce. No
sauce is weird for this one.
Your sausage is weird.
I would say ours is spicier. Not heat,
but the flavor of the
sausage is more pronounced
in the US one compared to this.
So, I know in the US, our
sausage is made up of,
and from what I understand,
the UK sausage is made up of.
And that was all done in post.
I have no idea what it says.
Like, here's the thing.
I like the double, but needs more cheese,
needs to be drowning
in some sort of sauce.
But this one I'm assuming
then is double bacon.
No, this is not double bacon.
Wait, one, two pieces
of bacon's double bacon?
This is double for you guys? For real?
Yo, you're getting ripped off, guys.
Excuse me, you've made a mistake.
You come back in like, come
storming in and cut in the line,
be like, "Ah, you made a mistake on mine.
There's only one slice of bacon on this."
So, all right. Let's try
with this double bacon.
I mean, it's ham.
Yeah, that's standard. That's not double.
This is smart that they did the jam.
I don't know in the US they
have the squirtable one.
I mean, do I need to, like,
I mean, I know what a
muffin and jam taste like.
I'm not like ...
Harry: Have you had a
British muffin and jam?
If I eat this,
will I still have had a
British muffin and jam?
I think after this, I
still will have no idea
what a British muffin and jam taste like.
All right, all right, all right.
All right, everyone relax.
Oh, yeah, that is really good.
This tastes way better
than the crap that we have.
Like, way better!
So, I have just been
informed that in England,
these are just called
muffins, not English muffins.
Porridge. I'm from the US.
I don't know what porridge
is. I'm assuming it's oatmeal?
So, from what I can tell,
you can get porridge four different ways.
One with golden syrup,
looks a lot like honey;
one with strawberry jam,
straight from France;
one with sugar, which
they did not include;
and then one plain.
So, first I'm just going
straight porridge, no chaser.
Yeah, that has no flavor to it.
Leon: Have some golden syrup on the side.
Yeah, all right.
So, I've been informed that
golden syrup is good stuff.
I don't know what's the
difference between golden syrup
and I guess whatever other syrups.
You're right, it's like,
it's not quite maple syrup,
but it's pretty close.
Makes it much better, obviously.
Joe: All right. Overall, Harry,
of the American exclusives,
what were some of your likes
and some of your dislikes?
Hm. Some of the things I liked,
you guys have a much bigger
breakfast menu than we do.
I did like the McGriddles.
They did live up to Joe's
pretty high billing.
Joe: Mm-hmm.
I also think that your bacon
is much better than ours.
So I think maybe the double
Quarter Pounder with bacon
was a strong highlight there.
Some dislikes, there's a few.
I don't like the
biscuits. I'm sorry, guys.
I think they are, like,
for a British person,
too similar to a scone.
So we can't really mentally differentiate
between the two, and it's just quite dry.
And also I think, like,
making your burgers deluxe
by just adding loads of mayo, some tomato,
and lettuce just is a bit underwhelming.
Not really a deluxe vibe for me.
Joe: So, if you could
bring one thing to the UK
from the US, exclusive, what would it be?
If I could take one of these exclusives
that I've tried today back to
the UK with me for our menu,
I think I'm going to have to pick
the bacon, egg, and cheese McGriddle.
I think it was really good.
It's a bit of a twist on the
classic McMuffin formula.
Feels a little bit more decadent, maybe,
a little bit more sweet.
And, yeah, just really good fun.
I like the emphasis you guys
place on your breakfast menu.
Joe: And what was the thing
you just hated the most,
you're like, "Ugh, let
that stay in the US"?
Well, the thing that I hated the most
and would want to remove
from all possible menus,
it's tricky. There are a couple.
But I think it might have
to be the sausage biscuit.
It was so dry.
And the notion of a
biscuit-slash-scone breakfast sandwich
to a British person is just too bizarre.
I can't get my head around
it. And, yeah, not the best.
Gotta say, I really disliked your bacon.
Your bacon is weird.
It ruined everything that it was on.
I love bacon, but your bacon
is just, it is bizarre.
The things I liked the most,
I obviously like the curry dipping sauce.
I like the banana milkshake,
separately, obviously.
That triple chocolate
chip cookie was good.
Harry: All right, Joe,
you gotta pick one thing
to take back with you
to the US from our menu
and you gotta pick one thing to remove
from our menu forever.
I'm taking back the curry dipping sauce.
I've wanted to try that since
we shot the first episode.
And then, take off your menu,
I mean, those veggie
dippers were pretty dismal,
but I don't want to leave
vegetarians out in the lurch.
The thing that's, like,
haunting me the most
was the grilled-chicken wrap.
I don't even think it was
grilled. I think it was boiled.
And I feel bad that that's
on your menu, and it's gross.
And I will do the UK a favor:
all grilled chicken off
the menu, McDonald's.
You're welcome.
All right.
[horn blaring]
Rolling.
I'm in New York, and I'm
outside a McDonald's.
I'm going to go inside,
take a look around,
and see how it compares to a
British McDonald's experience.